hello everybody hey how's everybody
doing hope you're doing fine
first I want to remind everyone once
more one more time we have a conference
coming up in Lusaka Zambia Zambia and
some pretty interesting people always
show up so if you want to have a good
time you want to have an exotic vacation
short vacation perhaps meet on an exotic
land with all this your chance why meet
Africa this is it I've been to northern
Africa Morocco and Egypt and so on but
I've never been in South Africa and for
those of you are a little scared you
know you say well you know I don't know
about these lands you know here's a
couple pictures from Lusaka there's a
skyline not so bad
I mean it's civilized okay so don't be
so afraid okay if that's what keeps you
away I also want to remind everyone they
can download the book we uploaded the
other day to the site you go to the rope
hypothesis calm and if you go to books
you'll find this book that's been there
now for over a week at least and you can
download this for free it's a hundred
and sixty page book it puts you up today
brings you up to speed on the rope I
potus's okay so and for any of those who
have a second language and master it may
be mother tongue horse or whatever that
here's uh you can you didn't help me
translate some of the book to different
languages we're in the process of
translating them now and you if you know
a different language you know it pretty
well too to be able to do a translation
right we do a Google translation first
and then you just kind of go in there
with your little brush and fix it up a
little bit and yeah please mail us a
tocar
hotmail calm and we'll be glad to send
you the word file for you to translate
okay anyways I had a lot of comments
this time around so i'ma do my best to
get them today because there's a lot of
issues to address some of the things
people don't understand others other
issues are questions people have in
their minds certain things they can't
figure out or answer or they cannot
visualize and it's important to clarify
those things before we move on okay so
let's go with the first comment that I
received or one of the comments that I
received we can't see space because all
spots on the night sky including dark
zones are loaded with electromagnetic
threads this notion that you know that
several people have over over the years
you know said this whether it's whether
the threads cover the entire space and
we're looking at threads and since we
can't see the thread then we're looking
at space but we're actually our eyes hit
are hitting on all kinds of threats out
there and the answer is no the answer is
if space were a physical object like an
ocean there would be more ocean than
threads okay and here I'm gonna put it
in a little picture so that you can see
what I'm talking about here's the two
galaxies okay and they're connected by
ropes okay and so every atom in one
galaxy is connected to every single atom
in another galaxy that's the theory okay
and that's the hypothesis from there we
derived theories of gravity and light
and so on so you can see that in in
order for there to be ropes each rope
has to be enveloped or encapsulator
any way you want to look at it it has to
be covered in space okay so to speak and
so yeah there is more space between two
galaxies than there are ropes
electromagnetic growth which is what we
are proposing
okay we're saying that every atom in the
universe is interconnected for those who
just dropped in and don't know
everything of what this site is about
and here we stretch the galaxy farther
apart okay so now you can see what
happened to the ropes the ropes here
were a little more wide as they reached
the galaxy and here you can see that it
becomes almost like a single coaxial
that all kind of merge the longer the
greater the distance between galaxies
and yes how we would see the dromeda
galaxy from our galaxy our galaxy is
that one on the lower right and we see
it almost as a as a single dot in the
sky I mean we can't see the Andromeda
galaxy at all and it's bigger than our
entire Milky Way galaxy and we can just
barely see this galaxy fact that we if
you put your eye there you know that's
what you would see would see just a
little dot why because all those ropes
come in as a single coaxial they're all
bunched up together they act as a single
one almost that's why gravity is so weak
at such great distances it acts as like
a single coaxial okay another comment so
the point there you know there's there's
more space than then threads or ropes
right much more if we look at space as a
volume of something space under the rope
model is nothing absolutely nothing what
does nothing mean nothing means that
which has no shape in contrast the rope
does have shape so we have something
that has shape and it's not inside it's
not in its it's not within because there
is no
container called space space is nothing
that which has no shape
not even God and cross space because he
has nothing to cross there are no
borders to step across into another
universe no such thing not even God can
cross space beside the fact that he
would lose a shape because of its space
that would give them that shape okay and
here we have another comment says I
would I use to light your robe theory
because it makes sense good
but seeing today putting Masanori
heretical physics under religion and
philosophy under science doesn't make
sense anymore
I understand they're not perfect but
it's testable whoa and works for now
okay
unlike your theories test them make
predictions on them I can't follow this
channel anymore I like my head without a
tinfoil okay let's see if I can get my
reply up here here's my tinfoil hat okay
and so what do we answer well the first
issue is that it's not a rope theory
it's a rope hypothesis and obviously
this individual is just went through
there superficially and because of that
he he just kind of you know it happens
to many people they come here and they
say oh I like that idea you know all the
atoms are interconnected okay that that
sounds nice but when they go in a little
deeper they find they hear things you
know that they don't want to hear you
know and with this site is about
primarily is this paradigm shift on the
scientific method okay we have a new way
of looking at science we're saying that
anything that happened at least since as
early as the 17th century so-called 7 C
17th century scientific revolution all
the way to today
none of that is science okay we
dismissed that as religion this is what
they did is religion science is
something else
science is explaining mechanisms
rationally you have to as applied to
physics okay
you have to explain our mechanism
rationally what I mean by rationally
that you don't move concepts around what
have they been moving for the last 400
years well they've been moving waves
which are concepts there's no physical
object called wave they've been moving
mass concepts like moving weight around
you know you don't move weight you move
the elephant not the weight of the
elephant okay you don't move
singularities you don't move the center
of masses you don't move energy you
don't move your Trent you don't transfer
information you know we don't transfer
information or attach it you know I
don't know I've never played baseball
with information you know it's it's
always been with the balls and someone
down the line we don't use force we
don't use field we don't use time all
those words have nothing to do with
science and so when you start moving
those around start warping time and
traveling through trying and treating
time like a like a medium then that's
not science we call it religion and it's
the worst kind of religion we could all
imagine God well we cannot imagine it's
four dimensional space kind okay so
that's where we run into trouble with
with all this so yeah there's been a
paradigm shift on the scientific method
and science is rational explanations and
the reason math let me put this guy back
in there the reason he he objected he
said putting maths in theoretical
physics under religion yeah exactly math
has nothing to do with fit with physics
or with science because math can only
describe physics explains now I have not
put math in religion I put mathematical
physics in religion what is mathematical
physics mathematical physics is the
physical interpretations that the the
mathematician derived from their
equations that's something else
math is one thing it's a language
not even part of science because it's a
language of descriptions and science we
don't describe in physics we don't
describe we explain we explain a
mechanism that's that's the what we
changed we're saying and that's and we
had the change of me as no one has
defined the word science in the last
10,000 years and we'll get into that in
a minute but here the the issue is that
you know we don't we have no definition
first we add that you find it and second
the definition that everybody uses
inform me has to do with descriptions
they include math because math the
medical physics gives you rational
explanations as a result of interpreting
their equations in terms of particles
that's where the problem is the problem
is part of it we cannot explain a single
phenomenon of nature invisible
phenomenon with particles okay you
cannot explain what particles and
they've been trying for the last 400
years they finally gave up on particles
unreal particles on what they call
classical particles they gave up on that
at the turn of the century of the 20th
century right first quarter of the 20th
century they changed all that and a
particle became the word they continued
using the word particle but the word but
that particle was not a particle it was
a concept it was an abstract concept it
was a vibration of a field in those days
it was a bundle of energy and then
somehow today it's been converted into a
an excited field and so what we have
today when when he talked about a
particle they don't mean a particle they
don't mean that like a speck of dust
that's not what they mean they mean
there's a vibration of a field okay and
this vibration of a field somehow
travels at great speeds they can't
explain that because that's when they
use the particle again they forget about
the field because the field is supposed
to be like an extended web that covers
the entire universe and they say that's
that's essentially what we have out
there and then when the field vibrates
locally that we see it as a particle
okay so how does the particle travel if
the field is
rating locally and that's when they get
rid of the field and now they continue
with the particle is there now the party
go now they treat is a little ball and
now they continue with us little ball
say the ball travels up 300,000
kilometers per second or whatever the
great speeds and this is the problem the
problem is they don't have a physical
interpretation and most people out there
that that irrational that have a head
under under next you know they want an
explanation of how gravity works how a
magnetic well how a magnet attracts
another how what electricity is how the
atom works this is these are people want
qualitative answers they want
explanations that they can visualize and
take home with them and they say ok I
see what you're saying and they can
visualize it understand it right now
people don't understand nothing they
can't understand anything coming out of
the establishment and and the only
conclusion all these people say was
thank God that someone understands all
that we have all these great minds out
there from can bridge and harboured who
can interpret all that math and
understand what's going on there because
I don't understand squat and it turns
out that all these invisible mechanisms
are kids stuff our kindergarten stuff
and you say you're kidding bill no I'm
not kidding you it's it's more difficult
to explain how a car runs then to
explain how gravity works the mechanism
ok the mechanism of gravity is
kindergarten stuff once you figure out
the invisible entities that mediate
gravity why does you know here we have a
pen and if also for game so balls always
do the experiment million times if you
want to be you want to be satisfied you
let go of a spoon you let go a fork you
have a baby they all fall to the floor
ok and you say magic magic because you
can't see the meteors that's the only
you can't see what's what agents are
mediating that invisible transaction
that's the only reason it's mysterious
sounds like ho we'll never figure it out
it's it's dumb phone it sits over my
head now very easy once you make the
invisible agents the mediators that
mother nature uses its kids though it's
baby stuff it's for kindergartners you
don't need to take any math you don't
need to all you need to do is understand
the mechanism once you see the visible
make the invisible visible that's all it
is and so what these people have done is
try to figure out through math through
equations to particles through
experiments and of course none of those
are the route none of those are the path
to understanding how mother nature runs
through invisible stuff that's what it
is and so yeah we don't need any math
and you have people get upset when you
say that because they said Oh
for 400 years we've been using math and
now you're telling us that we don't need
math sorry yeah you know we never needed
math that's why the none of these people
can explain it because they've been
using math they developed math to
ridiculous levels and today we have no
explanations whatsoever for the simplest
mechanism and I'll get to that in a
second here anyways in fact we don't do
any testing let me put this back up here
so you can follow along so as I
understand they're not perfect perfect
perfect
who is it Anselm we talked about
perfection of God you know need proof
God through perfection but it's testable
well in science we don't test anything
okay it's technology that tests and
works okay so if you're talking about
testable and working you're talking
about something else you're not talking
about science and then test them make
predictions in science we don't make
predictions sorry that's astrology
you're in the wrong field we don't do
predictions it's math that introduced
predictions in great measure because
once you have an equation you know you
can say well how fast is the car running
the cars running at 50 miles per hour
good that means that if everything if
nothing else changes everything
continues like that in one hour that car
will be 50 miles away so you can predict
with an equation
what have you explained you haven't
explained anything all you did was make
a prediction what is a prediction a
description that's all it is so you
described that the car is going to be
from instead of a point a is going to be
a point B in one hour because if
everything else is equal traveling at 50
miles per hour it'll be at 50 miles away
from a which is at point B so you can
predict that doesn't tell us anything
that's good maybe for technology which
other which is a bigger story still but
for sure you're not explaining anything
explanations you get explain a mechanism
and that's not what mathematical physics
so-called science does and yeah so
people get upset when you say math has
nothing to do with physics and neither
that which works we don't care if it
works or not
computers work not because quantum
mechanics is is rational or even correct
or anything or because they understand
it no they work computers work because
we develop them by trial and error you
try one thing it doesn't work you you
learn from then you say okay next time
I'll make it smaller or bigger or longer
or higher or whatever you change
something and what you did you still
don't understand just try one thing
right after another until you get it
right it was it Thomas Alva Edison he
said I'm failed I've tried I just found
10,000 ways that don't work and that's a
synthesis of technology anyways yeah he
says I can't father I like my head
without a tinfoil hat yeah okay but he
said you know anything related to
opinion like you know I don't like this
and I think you're wrong or right all
that has to do with religion that's
opinion that's your personal opinion so
none of that enters science okay okay
let's move on here here we had another
comment okay and individual says I hope
it continues to grow
the rope theory that's interesting
because he says rub theory the same
thing as the other guy you know now it's
known as the Rope hypothesis okay and
people don't understand the difference
between theory and hypothesis when they
say that gay theory is an explanation
hypothesis is an assumption an
assumption is not an explanation and not
everybody understands that that's part
of the change that we've got the
assumption only carries for the purposes
of physics okay
the here I'll summarize it with a little
bit here so that you can see what I'm
talking about
okay the assumptions only include the
objects the definitions and initial seen
again I give the example detective goes
to a crime scene the first thing he
wants to look at is what were the
objects like a knife stuck to a person's
back the person dead on the ground those
are the objects maybe maybe some
fingerprints blood whatever definitions
you need to know what a crime is what
stabbing means what you know the
different words that you use in that
business the detective business and then
you describe the initial scene that's
before you can tell us what you think
happened which is the explanation of the
event okay so that's what a hypothesis
is it's a set of assumptions and the
assumptions include the objects the
definitions and the initial scene the
first few the first few frames of the
film the the film strip that's what it
is of what what you saw
okay the staircase the lamp on the floor
was crooked you know whatever you saw
you set the scene so that people can
visualize that from there now you can
build your theory on top of that and say
look this is what I think happened
that's the way it works and these people
don't understand that they think that a
hypothesis is a theory that has no
evidence or it's a speculation it's a
speculative theory so they have no no
provision for the objects for the
definitions they have no provision for
any of that or for the initial scene so
that's the problem the problem they have
no
no provision for assumptions they go
directly into the theory and they say oh
we're already in the theory you missed
the assumptions assumptions we don't
care about those you know so yeah this
is one big part of the problem
Oh scientists disagree with Bill's
definition of science well let me put a
little something here on the side so
that you can follow along give me a
second here get so many of these you
know yeah first one tongue-in-cheek that
he thinks it should be promoted now
these people who are not into promotion
of the Rope hypothesis whether they just
the scientists disagree with my
definition science is not democratic you
don't get to vote for definition you
don't get to vote for definitions like
you don't get to vote for whether God
exists or not I mean people do but
that's religion on both sides of that
divide right in other words in in
science what we do we try to find the
best definition we can for a word that's
crucial that makes or breaks a theory
and people have to get on in the ring
with their shield and with their sword
they have to fight for their definitions
if they can't defend their definition
they get out of the ring they lost so
this is not an issue of voting and
saying oh that's not what we always
called science first of all we have no
definition of science okay and that's
another issue we should mention to those
people who have just pounced upon this
area this channel let me put this other
one here
let's continue with us what the hell
these are the definitions you'll find
out there you'll see the first one I
think was from Ono second was from this
at Wikipedia first one is one you'll
find on the Internet
I can't remember what the site was and
you have NASA at the bottom and the
first one says systematic study instruct
the structure and behavior of the
physical and natural world through
observation and experiment the second
one says organizes knowledge in the form
of testable explanations and predictions
well obviously those two are very
different so we don't have a definition
from the official world out there
establishment on which they can agree
they have no idea what science is and
then you have not so there says science
consists of observing the world by
watching oh great so you've got and
you're a scientist so so yeah we got a
problem because these people are saying
you know that that first of all they
they have no idea what science is okay
and so yeah it's not a question of
saying that you disagree with my
definition or that all the scientists
disagree because you know right now we
have no definition okay let's get this
one back in there
yeah so what's the issue the issue is
that this individual says he even
manipulates language to suit his
definition no you you whether you
manipulate it or not you have to define
the terms okay that's the issue so so
you must define the terms here it is
again okay you have to define your terms
because you gotta be explaining a
mechanism if you're doing physics and
you need to know what what words to use
if you're going to define the word
object and are you gonna use the word
object or you're gonna treat things as
objects you better know what an object
is and if you can't define the word
object or you have a different
definition well we have better known
what you mean by the word object if
we're gonna follow your presentation
okay and then in ordinary speech form
shape forum equals shape but in physics
they are the same okay yeah that's
that's what I'm saying and he's quoting
me there okay and he says if he can't
explain the universe with ordinary
speech then he should be explaining any
he should be any should not I guess be
explaining anything at all and he
belongs in the same category as the
scientists he denigrates well you know
the issue is that you know whether you
in physics we only have shape and no
shape okay that's all we have shape and
no shape and for all people who want to
challenge religious folk traditional
religions it's very easy you just say
ask them not whether God exists or this
or that ask him whether God has shape or
has no she is got an object or he's got
a concept okay I mean if God is love
intelligence information whatever in
other words you can think of energy then
God is a concept and that's what you're
praying to a concept if on the other
hand God has shape he's an object and
that's the way we treat these words in
physics science in general right
and so yeah we have to define and we
define in terms of shape and no shape
now he says he wants to make a
distinction between form and shape many
many people like to do that because
that's what they learn in ordinary
speech when they went to the high school
college or whatever and so they say well
form is not the same thing as shape
that's their notion and they say shape
applies to something like you know A to
D figure like triangle whereas form is
applicable to something that is 3 D or 3
times you know 3 dimension okay and so
we have several problems there you know
because that means you're not defining
object you're saying that there are
different kinds of objects there are 2d
objects and 3d objects that's one issue
so you still haven't distinguished you
haven't defined the word object by
distinguishing between form and shape
okay so it doesn't really matter in in
science but then there's the other issue
you have 3d shapes such as Q's perfect
ideal tubes you know there is no such
thing out here standing called a cube
perfect one right and so what do we do
with those you know where do we put
those we put them under form or under
shape because you can only see a perfect
cube you have to imagine it because all
they can do is project it onto 2d okay
you can't have a 3d cube a perfect 3d Q
out here and even if you do it with a
hologram you know I mean you can't get
it you can't get a perfect cube no
matter what you do and so we don't have
perfect cubes in the real world they
don't exist and so you know again we're
talking about different kinds of objects
and not and you haven't distinguished
between shape and form at least for the
purposes of physics so yeah no that
doesn't work and and again what this
individual has to do he's got to define
the word object in the alternative yeah
you got to give me a definition
something we can sink our teeth into and
he says if Bill wants to call rational
science that part which I refer to as
interpreter
the results obtained through
experimentation observation that is his
prerogative however that is not the
definition of science yeah and again we
don't we don't we have to fight for our
definitions it's not that we we simply
accept them because of tradition okay
because that's what our teacher told us
that's one issue but then here we have
another issue and that's what he's
saying here he's saying you know
experimentation he says however that is
not the definition of science that is
only a small part of a scientific
process process I think you know what is
he talking about first of all we have no
definition of science second what does
he mean that process process of what I
mean what what is science what does he
mean that science is a process is it a
process of learning that's it which is
what we do in school we just memorize a
poem and we're scientists because we we
learned we made progress in our learning
science has to serve some purpose you
can't just say that science is you know
whatever everybody's been doing so far
because as I showed a minute ago we
don't have a definition okay and then we
have the the issue that they have no
explanations for almost anything here we
had the other day I'll put it once more
up here mr. John Baez and his crackpot
index and he says what he says ten
points for arguing that while the
current well-established theory meaning
general relativity and quantum mechanics
right predicts phenomena correctly it
doesn't explain why they occur or fails
to provide a mechanism yeah these people
are not into mechanisms at all they're
not explaining mechanism so so we're
never gonna find out any qualitative
stuff we're never gonna find out how
gravity works but give because nobody's
working on it and nobody's working on it
or gets funds or for research or
whatever because it's not a part of
science according to them so this notion
that this individual has that you know
little by little we're going
approach knowledge or we're going to be
doing studying forever until we figure
it up he's totally out of his mind okay
nobody nobody is investigating these
issues let me put this up again one more
time this is Niels Bohr and his crew
here
Susskind the Neo Susskind
professor from Stanford University and
Richard Fineman which a lot of people
know he was a pro kleh Nobel Prize 1965
I think it was and these people tell you
they don't understand their theories
that's what they're saying yeah and I'll
just read the last thing again I think I
can safely say that nobody understands
quantum mechanics nobody understands
quantum mechanics please read my lips do
not keep asking yourself if you can
possibly avoid it how can it be like
that nobody knows how it can be like
that the more you see how strangely
Nature behaves the harder it is to make
a model that explains how even the
simplest phenomena phenomena actually
works so theoretical physics has given
up on that nobody is doing qualitative
stuff nobody in quantum mechanics at
least right is trying to understand
mechanisms that's that's over with it
died at the beginning of the quarter the
first quarter of the 20th century nobody
is doing that anymore
and people don't understand they say no
we have computers you would have a
computer if quantum were wrong they say
stupid things like this or will you and
have G GPS of general relativity were
wrong or ought to be wrong they say
stupid things like this and no they have
no idea of the mechanism they try one
thing they try another until they figure
it out and then now the technology
develops that has nothing to do with
knowing what a magnetic field is and how
a magnet what the mechanism is between
two magnets for attraction or repulsion
so the people don't understand that
that's what we they haven't figured out
yet none of that and we haven't figured
that out despite all the math and
despite 3,000 years of brainstorming all
kinds of
nonsense since the Greeks all the way to
today
and here we have another set of
questions here or issues the essentials
of Sciences business says evidence
gathered in experiments and observations
so is that what science is about
evidence who introduces evidence
I thought the it was a prosecutor and
the defense attorney aren't those the
guys who introduced evidence in a
courtroom why do they do that I mean why
would anyone introduce evidence
well they introduce evidence because
they're trying to persuade and convince
the jury to get on their side of their
case they're trying to convert them
they're trying to recruit them to their
side of of the battle there that's why
you introduced seven so evidence is
there only to persuade and convince
evidence has nothing to do with science
science we have to explain a mechanism
objectively whether you believe it or
not that's your personal business it
doesn't concern science you might like
the theory until I like that theory I'm
gonna take it as mine from now on fine
that's fine that's your religion has
nothing to do with science that's your
opinion now you know the fact that
someone explains that angels you know
move the curtain around that's his
theory right you say yeah I like that
theory I like the angel theory so he
convinced you you know you should you
said look every time I stand in here you
know the the the curtain moves that's
the spirit of my great-grandma that's
moving it and yeah maybe he should just
shut the window I mean but the point is
you know someone believes the evidence
whatever evidences is introduced there
and says oh well I believe in the theory
well that's his personal business the IV
believes in the theory we just care
about the objective explanation how did
the curtain move well this guy says an
angel did the other guy said no a bunch
of particles hit the the curtain now
that guy says no it was a waves - all
these fields that extend all the way the
edge of space-time
so they have all these different
theories and our we were interested in
knowing what each one has in the inside
is you know is his head we want to hear
mechanisms then you choose which one you
think is best for you but when you say
well let me prove it to you I now you
now your hair twisting arms now you're
introducing evidence to persuade to
convince me that's why evidence has
nothing at all to do with science and
that's why the mathematicians the
mathematical physics physicists
physicists they've been introducing
evidence why because they're more
interested in persuading than they are
in explaining because they know they
can't explain as you just saw they don't
understand their own theory so they just
introduce evidence to prove to those
people who are not you know very
well-versed in mathematics and in
physics in issues of physics and yeah
they're just trying to recruit them
that's all it is they're trying to
convince them yeah I know see it look I
can explain it here's the evidence and
then they tell you a particle can be of
two places at once or that time can be
warped and so when you look at those
explanations you know something wrong
here I mean how do you know and when you
push them against the wall people who
know a little more about visit these
people say well you know we we don't
understand how this universe works but
that's not what the people out there
believe but laymen believe that these
guys know because otherwise we wouldn't
have all this technology that's their
reasoning and and this is the problem
yet we have the circular thing going on
in in society where we have these
mathematicians they tell you in your
face we don't understand our theories
the other guys say well yeah you do
because otherwise we wouldn't have the
technology and when you try to question
them they said now we don't understand
it you know what we do is mathematics
and we don't care about the physical
interpretation about the mechanisms okay
and so this fellow says theories about
the evidence
that move from the particular to the
general the requirement that
contradicting evidence falsify a theory
falsified falsify again as belief its
opinion what is false to you is true to
me and vice versa you know maybe maybe
God is true to you you know and you say
you know God exists and I have proved
and I have evidence and I've convinced
myself and look at all the people who
believe come to my church and you'll see
all the people who believe in that same
God and I have proof and you know what's
he trying to do he's just trying to
convert you he's trying to produce
evidence to persuade you to believe like
he does that's all he's doing
that's not science and so every time
someone talks about evidence or
falsifying you know falsification only
means that he's going to introduce
evidence to try to show you something to
try to convince you that you're either
right or that you're wrong whichever it
doesn't matter and we don't do that
inside
we don't use falsification that's not a
criterion of Sciences it's pop Aryan
Karl Popper Austrian so-called
philosopher who introduced that and
everybody bought into that but what is
it it's it's nonsense
if falsification only means that you're
going to convince somewhere of something
you know it's easy to falsify I mean
quantum mechanics I mean the guy says a
particle can be at two places at once
yeah sure showed me that at the lab you
know how are you gonna show them is
something and you can't prove in any way
so it's sound unfalsifiable proposal
okay so but these people get away with
that they say oh yeah that's what we
verify why because they do everything
with particles and yeah when they can't
explain it they say well the particle
was two places at once and we're done
hey so it works so yeah there's nonsense
about falsifiability and presenting
evidence as absolutely nothing to do
with science and you know these people
are educated actually brainwashed
in high school and some of them go up to
college and then you get further
brainwashing and this is what they
repeat and then the next the generation
repeats the same thing in the next one
and the next one in the next one that's
how we got to today because no one
challenges these notions they say oh no
no all the scientists can't be wrong
it's like saying that all the
Flatlanders can't be wrong or
flat-earthers
or all the old relatives cannot be wrong
yeah of course or all you know all
Catholics cannot be wrong
you know they can't all be Romney how
many have a billion people who believe
in God they can't all be wrong candy so
this this issue about being wrong and
voting and introducing evidence and
falsifying or using this falsification
criterion has nothing to do with science
but this is what they've brainwashed
people with and this is what people
repeat yeah okay here's another comment
however it is gathered evidence it is
gathered evidence gathered evidence must
be unambiguous and repeatable and it
must be objected to impartial observers
must come to the same conclusion uh-huh
so do we have a similarity of criteria
out there I mean has everybody come to
the same conclusions let's see if I can
find it here where is it here's a
quantum mechanics conclusions okay this
is from a group that follows mr. Bohr
you know his disciplines what does he
say your have some idea that come out of
CERN the complex over there in
Switzerland right the LA see Large
Hadron Collider and they have run
experiments repeatedly so we we meet the
repeatable criterion and he's proposed E
and they have
included that a particle can be at two
places at once light is both a particle
and a wave and virtual particles pop in
from the void by magic that they're at
their whim or at the whim of the
mathematicians magic wand and here you
have rationality from another quarter
which is the general relativity and
something similar yep people like NASA
and the LIGO gang and like oh we're the
guys who supposedly discovered gravity
waves okay and then run again many
experiments repeatedly so we have the
repeatable criterion we've covered that
one right and what have they concluded
well they concluded the earth dragged
space around hey your space is nothing
and drags threatens Earth's better drags
it around they allegedly prove that with
gravity probe B and some other
experiments and they claim that there
are some things called they call black
holes zero the objects zero-dimensional
opposite they have no volume whatsoever
no size and these non entities crush
matter out of existence that's what most
people believe out there today
dark matter again it's a concept that
compels starts to travel faster
it's like saying love of enables objects
starts to travel faster so is his
criterion valid at all I mean you know
what is he saying here is he saying that
we should do repeatable experiments and
reach the same conclusion I'd like to do
that experiment all the time you know
here's a pen and I'll let go of it
always falls to the floor just in case
you know you say we it's repeating its
repeatable look here I'll repeat it I
can repeat it all day long had a bunch
that's here hey you have pen okay same
pen by the way maybe there's a slight
difference in way but whenever I that
good always falls to the floor
so the
experiment was repeatable right I can
repeat it a few more times if that helps
anyone out there right do we come to the
same conclusion what conclusion what's
the conclusion what is gravity
haven't have I figured out what gravity
is by you know throwing pens a million
times we've been throwing stuffs baby
spoon since almost week since the days
we were born and we still don't know
what gravity is we cannot explain
gravity in other words they cannot
explain that early mathematical
physicists cannot explain Riley and Y
and they never will because the first
time you see particles second they're
using equations third they're running
experiments at nauseam you know means so
what you ran an experiment what did you
prove with the experiment how are you
going to figure out something that is
invisible and intangible such as the
mediator of gravity you're gonna figure
out by running experiments the way you
do it is the way I do it you grab a beer
gang excuse me grab a beer sit back put
your feet on top of the your desk and
you think you try to visualize what
Mother Nature could be using as a
mediator for gravity for magnetism for
electricity for quantum jump in in the
case of the atom and all these invisible
things that we have out there and once
you visualize that then you can explain
you can explain how the mechanism works
but if you're just gonna go to the field
and do an experiment experiment on one
what are you gonna do we know gravity by
heart you know what gravity is things
fall to the floor just explain why doing
another experiment will give you an
insight no of course not so it's not an
issue of running experiments
igneel diagnose you forever no okay
here's another comment negative comments
again add too many of those and this has
to do with you made a comment this
individual by his crackpot index he says
the aim of this is not to stop the
development of new ideas but to
eliminate crackpot ones that are
inconceivable or impossible based on
current knowledge but just mention a
couple I mean you know are these
crackpot theories or am I wrong I mean
here's here's a Einstein and his general
relativity are those crackpot theories
the earth dragged space around itself
black holes are zero dimensional
so-called objects actually no object
there because an object is that which
has shame and this nothingness crushes
matter out of existence has infinite
mass it is that the current knowledge is
that the is that a crackpot theory how
about dark matter I mean you know here's
a concept that compels stars to travel
faster and on the outside of a galaxy
you know it's like saying love or
intelligence forces stars to travel
faster are those crackpot theories or
should we include consider them as such
and here's you know quantum mechanic
wrack pot theories here we have a
particle can be in two places at once
is that crackpot or or is that
mainstream should we is this knowledge
light is both a particle and a wave
so-called wave packet virtual particles
pop in from a void at their will I mean
you know are these the crackpot theories
he's talking about so so yeah people
have made up their minds that whatever
comes from the establishment has
Authority has a PhD degree behind it
right and so they say ah no we can't
question that because he all these guys
they have PhDs they all agree so we're
not gonna question now we're gonna
question the lone gunman out there you
know the little outlaw who's rebelling
against all these people you know it's
not a question of or like I think it was
Galileo who said like you know the the
revolutions are created by one guy
they're not created by a team it's
always one guy who comes up with the
first idea and and that's the idea that
finally gets spread around it sometimes
it takes
long time but yeah a million people can
be all you know for all we care down to
patients it's gonna be the smart guy out
there who figures it out and so to say
that all these guys with PhDs are gonna
figure it out when all they do is repeat
you know parent whatever their teachers
gave them because it's the only way they
can you know dance then yeah I mean
we're gonna get the same thing over and
over and over again we're never gonna
make any progress and that's the status
quo today yeah okay here's another
comment and it goes like this
Bill's notion of single thread as
explaining all matter in the universe
may seem by some as a crackpot idea well
okay why what's crackpot about it I mean
is it any better to say particles in
rope which physically can move objects
as in the case of magnetism what can you
do with particles I mean that's what
quantum proposes can you do it with
space-time a concept can you do with
that is that crackpot so so again these
people like to use these words to to try
to you know to what does it belittle a a
theory because it's no because they
never heard of it and that's shock some
and they said no we've always done it
like this we've done it with particles
and we've done it with space-time are
those any any better are those any
better than flat there are theories I
mean why particles how can you pull with
a particle which is the only force that
quantum mechanic cannot explain you
can't you can't pull with particles you
can't throw particles and pull the
donkey you know try it try it in the
field do do an experiment you like to do
experiments go ahead and doing the
experiment and then he says I can place
a magnet on a table and move a metallic
object underneath that table yet I can't
touch or cut through that rope he's
referring to the electromagnetic rope
which is what we're proposing it's not
the rope in the case of magnets called
the thread but he can't tell the
difference it's just worse
worthless time spent on people like him
you know
he doesn't know the difference between
the rope and the thread he keeps easy to
grow the ropes go through each other and
they never appeared to get tangled well
that's easily addressed okay let's see
if we can get this in here so many of
these okay and here is I mean as an
object that which we can touch her see
which is what this individuals trying to
do he's trying to see and touch he says
I can't touch or cut the rope okay and
he obviously can't see it either right
can you see the air can you touch this
hi hypercube which is a four dimensional
cube proposed by general relativity they
they go through all this nonsense about
hypercube in hypersphere z-- right
concepts and you can't touch a concept
it's very hard to touch love it's very
hard to touch information you know but
you can't see here I mean that's that's
quite obvious I think right and if you
can't touch the air does that mean air
is not an object it's not a thing is air
a concept you know I feel it but I'm
touching a concept just because I can't
see it thank God you know mother nature
was smarter than this guy because you
know she made air invisible you know
mother nature got together with God and
with father universe all three of them
got together and they said look we're
gonna make some some humans dumb you
know but we can't make them all blind
that would be horrendous
even the devil felt that it was a bad
deal to do it that way so they made air
invisible and you know so because air is
invisible it doesn't exist it's not
there because oh we can't see it you
know I don't know where I don't know
what's going inside my mouth so yeah
these people think that an object is
that which you can touch and no we say
an object is that which has shape okay
now
the fact that it has shape on its own
without us seeing it you know doesn't
rule out shape is not that which you can
see and shape is not that which you can
touch shape is a different criterion in
fact see and touch require a second
object okay so yeah you can't use the
what he's trying to do there he's trying
to use his senses especially you except
the common sense right
try to use a census to you figure out
how to how to you know what invisible
entities mother nature uses to do
magnetism in this case okay and here you
see the electromagnetic rope okay and is
that an object I mean do you see
something there that has shape does it
have shape what I'm showing you there
yeah and here I can show you here this
is the rope does this thing have shape
in your opinion you might say whoa what
is shape you know people get into these
endless debates on what a shame well
it's very simple you know if you have
trouble if you never went to
kindergarten never learned shape you
know go to kindergarten today and you
know I have a cube see if I can put let
me get this one out for a second here
okay here's a cube rubik's cube that's
the best I could do okay and here's a
sphere okay just a ball okay and the
question is let's assume these have the
same volume the same color the same
material the same everything right you
go to kindergarten you ask the
five-year-olds at least maybe six years
old I don't know and you say though
what's the difference between these two
and I'm sure they're hugging right shape
now you learn what shape does so if you
don't know what shape is just go to
kindergarten and the kids will teach you
to teach you what shape is because
people seem to have trouble after they
go to college learning understanding
what shape is
that's not the point the point is that
shape is the criteria because it's a
universal criterion okay and none of the
others volume mass that which you can
touch that you which you can see
especially none of those qualify as a
proper definition of the word object for
the purposes of physics that's the issue
yes you we don't need to know what shape
is we just need to know the difference
between shape and running are we going
to say that which moves is that what an
object is no because running requires
several frames you have to define object
before you defined verbs and so what
we're comparing a shape against running
we're comparing of or verbs we're
comparing shape against see touch we're
comparing shape against mass so all we
need to know is which of these criteria
you're going to choose as the criteria
to define an object for the purposes of
physics that's what it's about okay so
it's not an issue of saying oh what is
shape now you don't have to go that far
all you need to know is the difference
between shape and running if you can't
tell that we'll go back to kindergarten
that's all I can say and do the
experiment see if you can figure out
what shape is okay anyways the other
issue there was touch this guy seems
that we can't touch it well here let me
enlighten you a little bit untouched
since he's such a smart individual right
okay touches zero distance that's what
touch is okay now if if there's more
than zero distance like in that first
case you have two objects but the
problem is that when you have zero
distance all you have is one object the
up the two objects have become one and
then you don't have any distance then
you can't talk about touch okay I know
this is over your head
all I can say is define touch and then
come back here with your question okay
try to be smarter next time my god
some of these people yeah before you can
cut the rope you got to touch
if you don't know what touch is well
then you got a lot of investigating to
do before you can criticize the Rope
hypothesis there's a lot of stuff that
is included in the book and you know you
just gotta find out what the arguments
are they're over the head of most people
here so we would rather not touch upon
that here okay yeah we do have criteria
for touch Y ropes
go or don't go through each other how it
does that how mother nature does that
magic trick okay and these are things
you know we try to talk about but not
here because some people can't even
handle the kindergarten stuff they don't
know what shape is and they you know
what an object is they don't know what
exists means and if you don't understand
those words which are key words in
physics and there's no use in talking
about something more complex
here's another comment okay so since
Bill likes to show movies to demonstrate
his mechanism is Bill please show me a
physical not a conceptualized rope that
has these properties
and he said he can't because it doesn't
exist and moreover he says you have to
assume that it well bill the assumption
is incorrect okay let's continue to
investigate until we get ever closer to
discovering the mysteries of the
universe well not only are we not closer
we'll never get any closer we're not
even close because in three thousand
years no one has figured out how
magnetism gravity etcetera work and they
won't because no one's investigating any
of that like biases said they're not
doing mechanisms first of all second the
other people say we don't understand our
own theories we don't know how it
operates out there because we can't see
anything
we're blind when we deal with these
things because none of these things are
tick touchable or seeable they're
intangible and invisible you
can't figure out gravity by running an
experiment in the lab and you know some
people with tiny brains they don't
understand what I'm saying so let me try
to say it again maybe someone out there
you know it brightens their mind a
little bit you can't figure out gravity
or magnetism - invisible mechanism you
can't figure them out by running an
experiment doing equations or mediating
them with particles but discrete
particles or particles which are not
particles like in quantum which are
vibration of fields or whatever you
can't throw it and unless you come to
grips with that you know yeah you're in
the wrong Channel and yeah we one of the
good things about this channel it weeds
out the riffraff when people find out
you know what this channel is about the
uh-oh this scares me because they're not
used to that they they're used to all
the nonsense they hear from you know the
big celebrities out there and so when
they come here it's like a shock
cultural shock okay scientific shock I
could okay so yeah some problems here
here's a another comment I guess it's
the last one I'm gonna deal with we're
gonna have to deal with good old
Aristotle and and Euclid some other time
I can show you a black hole and atom and
light oh man how I would sure would like
to I don't want to see your black hole
for sure but but I guess he's referring
to this where is it
see if I get it here it is this image
which some a group of so-called
scientist came up with and there's two
if you go to the well you can look it up
almost anywhere but I put two articles
one is from Wired the other one from BBC
News and they both tell you that this
was taken the stunt was done by a team
of people over a period of days you're
not looking at a photograph you're
looking at a collage that's the first
issue and he thinks it's a photograph oh
they took a picture well I we got to see
how they took that bill what is that
picture it's like when they show
pictures of atoms
people say thank you sent one of those
as well you know what is an atom and
people get the wrong idea they think
that these investigators out there these
researchers that they have photographed
an atom that they have this idea because
they see an image of an atom is you oh
look oh it's so so awesome you know yeah
they took a picture of an atom no one
has taken a picture of an atom you're a
fool if you believe that okay
no one has a picture of an atom you know
and I'll prove that you want proof you
want evidence okay we'll give you a
proof in evidence here's a here's proof
in evidence that there is no such thing
as atom that nobody's taking a picture
of an atom okay this is the atom we have
today this is the one that's used by
everybody to explain ionization and
electricity it's known as the planetary
atom invented by mr. Rutherford and pour
that's the one in use today and then at
the end of the show the mathematician
tells you oh by the way that's not a
random don't don't take it literally
it's like an analogy or whatever okay
you're not supposed to take that from
literally but that's the one they used
to do all their things that's the one
they use for ionization they say the
electron flies away and and now
electricity is the flow of these
electrons from one atom to another so
that's how they explain it any other
thing they have to explain because see
there that ring there that's not a hula
hoop okay that's the path okay it should
be see they they don't paint it right
but they should paint it with dotted
lines really to indicate that that's a
path that that's a night inner Airy and
the only anything that anybody has to
answer is what keeps the electron ball
gate tied to the nucleus what entity is
there between them what physical entity
is there between them and if you say
well there's none then you're putting
angels you're putting spirits in there
in that same space because you're doing
it with magic you're not giving me a
mechanism of why the electron pee
doesn't fly away spontaneously before
you ionize or produce electricity
so this is where quantum mechanics fail
miserably I can't answer and we'll never
it never will answer because you cannot
explain pull between two particles with
particles I don't care what but you put
in that space between the these the red
and the violet particle there you can
put particles you you still will not be
able to explain the mechanism of
attraction particles can't pull so what
are you going to put pull particles on
the outside pushing the electron beat
inwards what happens to those particles
when the electron bead flies away during
ionization and electricity so we have a
problem we have a problem because this
is nonsense and at least the quantum
mechanics a lot of them at least
acknowledge that this is not that this
is a nonsense picture of the atom and so
this individual he says that he can draw
an atom and he sent me to I don't know
where no no I want you to draw that show
me a picture of an atom anywhere on the
internet of one atom I want to see the
electrons I want to see the protons you
can use a s orbital you can use a p
orbital a D or I don't care which
orbital you want to illustrate
illustrate an orbital and show me what
your atom looks like and the best one
would be this one the hydrogen atom very
simple and regarding he says he also can
draw a picture of light well all I can
show you is what we have today for light
J and here it is these are the notions
that these are the pictures that are the
ideas that people have of what light is
some people say it's a flow of particles
electron beads or photon bees in this
case photon beads or maybe it's a
transfers wave so which one is aside
from the fact that a wave a transverse
wave is a bunch of vectors that's all
those little engine arrows are so there
is no such thing as a wave there's no
physical object called a wave and then
one guy at least uh illustrated his book
high-level guy the wave packet you know
that pretty cute so with an arrow in
Janeiro going through it it's a bed
spring with an arrow this is the notion
that the Mathemagician out there have of
light so if you have a better one show
me a picture of light he says he can
draw a light he can draw an atom he can
draw what was the other black hole okay
I like my vision of the black hole
better see if I can find it here I think
you'll like this one where is it give me
a second here
here it is okay so this is this is the
really the the best picture that you'll
find of a black hole
I get it up there Jesus give me a second
here
so I prepare it right okay here it is
that's the black hole that they took a
picture of and again it's is that a
black hole is that is that what we call
it worm hole there
yeah we like yep that's that's that's
what a black hole is that's all the
suckers who bought who ever believed in
black holes okay you really got to be
have a big problem in your mind if you
believe in a black hole because the
black hole has never been defined and
that's what these people don't
understand there is no fit no definition
of the word of the term black hole and
that you find it as a region regions
about a physical object and here they
say this region has so much mass that it
moves stars around from the distance
anything if that were true which is
nonsense
but what's the mechanism show me how
mass brings that star over and what have
they invented they invented the the
field you know you bend the field you
know you want to you want the football
to come rolling towards you but what you
do you curve the field over in the
football falls to your hands it was in
the depression so that's the mechanism
these individuals have come up with
because they have no other way of
explaining this yeah and so yeah we
think all of mathematical physics has
only your rational explanations it's not
science and that's why we need to change
all this we need to get rid of
mathematical physics completely anything
from Newton onwards is garbage let's get
rid of all of it
anyways we'll see you on is it Sunday
hopefully I get back to gold Aristotle
in Euclid
okay just so many questions that pop up
so we'll see you Sunday bye bye